[Musica]
[Applauso]
e se vi dicessi che noi viviamo qua
dentro
Sì perché il pianeta Terra è definibile
come un sistema chiuso per materia e
aperto per energia e allora dobbiamo
fare lo sforzo di immaginarlo come
sigillato in un enorme barattolo di
vetro da cui Nulla può entrare o uscire
tranne la luce del sole infatti la
materia sul pianeta è la stessa da che
il mondo si è formato miliardi di anni
fa mentre la luce del sole quella sì che
riesce a filtrare attraverso la nostra
atmosfera e contribuisce a creare quelle
condizioni che hanno permesso alla vita
di nascere e di svilupparsi fino ad oggi
Ecco in questo tipo di sistema a partire
dal 1800 circa l'essere umano si è
sviluppato secondo un modello economico
lineare
questo modello si basa sull'estrazione o
utilizzo di risorse di input quindi le
materie prime naturali ma anche le
risorse economiche umane l'energia e la
loro trasformazione in Un output
output sono i prodotti e servizi che noi
tutti i giorni consumiamo utilizziamo ma
anche rifiuti gli stessi derivati dai
processi di consumo e di produzione
E cosa è successo nel mondo applicando
questo tipo di modello per oltre 200
anni
ma intanto abbiamo raggiunto un
Progresso inimmaginabile in tutto il
mondo è cresciuta la qualità della vita
l'aspettativa di vita è crollato
l'indice della povertà estrema così come
quello della mortalità infantile o
ancora abbiamo aumentato indicatori di
accesso all'acqua potabile all'energia
all'educazione
l'altra cosa che è successa e che su
questo pianeta siamo sempre di più
siamo passati infatti dal primo miliardo
di persone raggiunto nel 184 a 8
miliardi raggiunti invece lo scorso 15
novembre e questa è la curva con cui
cresce la popolazione mondiale e lo ha
fatto appunto dal 1770 fino ai giorni
nostri è un tipo di crescita
esponenziale
e con una popolazione che cresce in
questo modo E allora quante risorse di
input abbiamo bisogno per il sistema
lineare quanti output stiamo immettendo
nel sistema
Ecco Considerate che si dice l'umanità
consuma in media all'anno
una virgola 75 Terre
la natura infatti ogni anno ci mette a
disposizione delle risorse secondo
quelli che sono i ritmi di rigenerazione
terrestre quindi la capacità della
natura di generare dei materiali
biologici che noi come esseri umani
possiamo utilizzare e anche la capacità
della natura poi di assorbire quello che
invece produciamo noi gli output
derivanti dall'attività umana
Ecco la velocità con cui prendiamo
risorse e immettiamo output è quasi
doppia rispetto a quella di
rigenerazione terrestre
ed esiste un giorno nell'anno in cui
terminiamo le risorse a nostra
disposizione si chiama overshote Day
e se veramente il modello economico
lineare fosse sostenibile Beh allora
dovrebbe cadere a fine dell'anno al 31
dicembre
quello che succede però è che con il
passare degli anni questa data viene
sempre prima nei mesi
A partire dagli anni 2000 Lovers su Day
è in piena estate a luglio
e questo è un dato di media tra i ritmi
di sfruttamento risorse e immissione di
output di paesi come gli Stati Uniti che
si pesano su quelli del sud del mondo
E se tutto il mondo invece andasse la
nostra di velocità quella italiana
ne consumeremo quasi tre di terre
2,7 all'anno
l'overshow Day in questo caso non
sarebbe a luglio
a dopodomani il 15 maggio
vuol dire che a partire da lunedì
generalizzando tutti noi inizieremo a
sfruttare risorse in modo insostenibili
e lo faremo per il resto dell'anno
è un po' Come finire lo stipendio il 12
del mese e per il resto del tempo andare
a consumare i nostri risparmi che quindi
in un determinato momento preciso
finiranno così come stiamo esaurendo
alcune delle risorse naturali della
terra
modello lineare da un lato prendo
risorse dall'altro e metto output Tra
questi c'è l'anidride carbonica CO2 un
Gas clima alterante e questa è la curva
di concentrazione della anidride
carbonica in atmosfera tra la fine del
1700 e i giorni nostri
noterete che segue lo stesso Trend di
crescita esponenziale della popolazione
terrestre
livelli così alti di concentrazione di
CO2 in atmosfera sono tra le principali
cause dell'innalzamento delle
temperature terrestri e quindi della
crisi climatica
pensate che in alcuni paesi del mondo
già abbiamo raggiunto una temperatura di
più 2 gradi Celsius 2 gradi
Ma che vuol dire alla fine che cambia se
in questa stanza abbiamo 18 20 gradi
E se invece proviamo a pensare a un
sistema un po' più complesso ad esempio
il nostro corpo
37 gradi stiamo bene ma iniziamo a
percepire la febbre più due gradi 39 il
nostro corpo è sottoposto a uno stress
importante se la temperatura aumenta
ancora per un tempo prolungato la nostra
salute è a rischio di collasso
Ecco nel 2100 secondo quelle che sono le
attuali politiche di mitigazione della
crisi climatica
si stima che raggiungeremo una
temperatura terrestre compresa tra i più
due virgola due gradi e più 3,5
un incremento di questo tipo di questa
portata quello che potrebbe fare poi è
incidere sui fenomeni meteorologici
estremi tra cui ci sono le ondate di
calore
E allora Questo potrebbe tradursi in
alcune aree del mondo in temperature
effettive di più sei sette gradi
rispetto ai livelli pre-industriali e
nel giorno più caldo dell'anno
e in tutto questo la l'economia non
smette di crescere
non smette continua e lo fa un ritmo
medio nel mondo del 3% all'anno
se qualcuno sembra poco Beh pensi che
qualsiasi cosa che cresce ogni anno del
3% in meno di vent'anni è raddoppiato e
nei prossimi anni continueremo a
crescere come popolazione saremmo 9 poi
10 miliardi entro il 2050 con un
aumentato fabbisogno di risorse di input
e con più output immessi in un sistema
che invece rimane lo stesso soltanto uno
è chiaro è oggettivo che il modello
economico lineare che finora ha
funzionato benissimo l'ho fatto per
oltre 200 anni Beh non può essere lo
stesso modello che ci consentirà di
vivere in un futuro di prosperità
condivisa
perché non tiene conto di un principio
che è talmente ovvio che spesso ce ne
dimentichiamo
viviamo in un sistema chiuso e questo ci
rende interdipendenti gli uni agli altri
e come esseri umani con la natura
in modo così profondo così importante
che il nostro benessere dipende da
quello dell'ambiente
Ecco questo contesto ci mette davanti
alla necessità di un cambiamento urgente
radicale dei nostri paradigmi di
riferimento che sia economico sociale e
culturale E questo forse rappresenta la
sfida più grande che come esseri umani
abbiamo mai affrontato la più importante
perché sistemica riguarda tutti
e poi è estremamente complessa è in
continua evoluzione
ed è chiaro che in questa transizione
avranno un ruolo determinante alcuni
attori tra cui i decisori politici e
anche quello che succederà in certi
settori chiave dell'economia pensate
alle energetico a quello dei trasporti
alle filiere alimentari
Ma è anche vero
che dietro queste grandi forze il
business i governi ci sono persone come
noi
e non dico in generale dico proprio come
me e come voi
le nostre scelte quotidiane di vita di
azione di consumo sono così importanti
da poter contribuire a quel cambiamento
da poterlo accelerare
da poterlo pretendere
nei prossimi minuti alle mie spalle farò
scorrere una serie di frasi che
rappresentano 10 azioni alla portata di
tutti
quello che vi chiedo e non appena
leggete una frase che per voi è vera
quindi un'azione che voi già fate allora
iniziate a battere le mani con un
applauso continuo
che non finisce più ad esempio se per me
è vera la quarta frase parto da lì e
inizio non mi fermo più fino alla fine
non mi fermo neanche se qualcuna delle
frasi successive magari per me non è
vera perché il senso è quello di sentire
l'impatto che possiamo avere insieme
anche a partire da una singola azione
pronti iniziamo
[Applauso]
Questo è il rumore che possiamo fare
insieme
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]